[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm Rhett and I'm
link this week at the round table a damn
lighting draw near oh
demons hey what
draw near people who are interested in
hearing about our latest video where we
hired an actual
true life Exorcist slash demonologist
from tick tock in order to
advise and protect us as we play
Dungeons and Dragons for the first time
in a video that was completely
documented on the Resurrected
interesting
or OG Channel youtube.com Rhett and Link
yes this is the second video
which in the producer parlance is 102.
okay yeah you know RLC 102 red Link
channel that's that's episode two the
technical term for it around in these
parts and it's just great to be getting
these videos out there you know it's
like we're trying to
you know we're not hitting the schedule
we're trying to do it once a month and
we were when we hatched this idea we
were very excited about it but I'm
interested to talk about the ideas that
the video tees up you know so this is
not really there's like yeah we'll talk
some behind the scenes about
how we made the video but the ideas and
the beliefs
that we're dancing with in this video
I think there's a good conversation to
be had
in that Realm
this is one of the First videos I would
say maybe the first video
outside of an ear biscuit
where we're directly addressing or using
something that kind of comes from our
faith POV for Content this is something
we never did no back in the day right we
we didn't we didn't know how to go about
things even when we were in the early
days making videos and we were still
thinking sort of in a like Christian
Mission mindset but we were like we're
not going to do that directly through
our video we're going to do that through
the Avenues that our videos create for
us and then of course uh we lost our
faith and became apostates uh and so
that particular strategy went out the
window but there were those many years
where we were just not talking about
what was happening the loss of faith and
all this stuff yeah it was complicated
it didn't translate into content
directly and
there's no readily
we don't ever intend to make good
mythical morning an outlet for these
types of things like you know we're not
gonna I'm not well you know we might do
something like okay we're gonna bring
some psychics on to GMM and test them in
some fun game or something like that but
it's always just to have fun and
uh to create something light-hearted and
we're not trying to take on
controversial subjects and not kind of
delve deep into like our perspectives
but this is the first piece of content
that the whole thing starts from this
because of who we are where we come from
and the mindset that we bring to
something
it kind of sets the stage for exploring
this thing
in an entertaining way I'm trying to
remember
how we came up with the idea do you
remember well link I have evidence oh
yeah because it
something clicked into place
yeah it was it was I could not remember
this uh but I went back to the doc so
basically
there was this document that had
just a Ab just a brained up a video of
video Concepts and
there was one of them that was called
Dungeons and Dragons and here's what it
reads growing up in the Evangelical
Church we were convinced that any kid
playing d d was regularly commuting with
the Devil
um
we enter the dungeon and face the dragon
along the way we unpack the phenomenon
of parents and specific culture spewing
misinformation based on fear and lack of
understanding so it was like
yeah is that it so that was the DND idea
that was the pitch it wasn't really a
pitch you know it's just like I had this
long list of things that was just like
hey not a lot most of them weren't fully
formed and then there was a second list
which was less defined General ideas and
it just says
uh Faith related given our public
reputation around leaving the Christian
faith this seems like fertile ground a
couple of starter ideas uh
get to know a Christian who says that
they regularly have Supernatural
experiences like this tick tocker who
claims to deal in demons demon eraser oh
you had oh so yeah so I so I yeah we
were thinking that
because you watch all and you allude to
this in the video that like the
algorithms serve up
spiritual really good idea content I'm
not going to oh you just read another
idea yeah okay well it's written down so
you can tell me yeah yeah you can remind
me of it later
what was I saying uh I watch this kind
of content yeah so the algorithm gives
you more of it and
so there was an idea there of but there
were two separate ideas yeah and it
wasn't
can we see an exorcism but I know that
we talked about that because there are
people who will post you you're gonna
have to tell me
the exorcisms on the internet
you can watch you can watch these things
yeah so I would say that most of the
content that I get served is just
um
like Christian or ex-christian content
in general and
you know I talk about the algorithm in
the in the main video The Dungeons
Dragons video but the interesting thing
that I found is that the tick tock
algorithm knows Tick Tock knows that I'm
an ex-vangelical
Instagram's algorithm is not as
sophisticated as The Tick Tock algorithm
and it thinks that I'm a Christian
interesting and so on Instagram I just
get like Christian content and I watch
it because I'm you know I'm still
fascinated I I I'm probably gonna make a
video about this about this because it's
a phenomenon of people who are no longer
a part of it who are still fascinated by
it you're a Christian on Instagram and
you're an ex believer
on Tick Tock yeah I mean it for me
that's proof right there because I'll
just get like but you're still watching
the the the sincere Christian content on
Instagram you're just watching it just
to keep an eye out or are you watching
this stuff it's a little more
entertaining it's entertaining to me I'm
entertained by in fact Jesse recently
tweeted
uh
she's like my husband loves to watch
Christians do take down videos of him of
you and laugh along the way while she
says I cuss like someone who learned a
curse in their 30s because she gets so
upset about it and I'm like legitimately
I'm so into it I love seeing them the
latest thing they've come up with or the
way they somebody's taking taking their
passion and their energy and they're
directing it towards taking you down
that's well well they're pretty great
let me just say that let me say that let
me just say that I'm for it the LA it's
not just me the last one I watched was
mostly about the fact that that you
became topachika uh oh great that was
your that's your latest like boy you
really crossed the line when you did
drip drag
like the sexual deviance that you are
now endorsing openly
uh for all the children
to completely lose their way like you've
dude you've crossed a lot and meanwhile
I'm over here looking at cat videos dog
videos and
um that was the latest one that
sometimes like wolves or mountain lions
trapped in like a snare and then
somebody has to come along and get them
out of it any drag Mount lines
nope interesting nope I did I did my
thing
I'm good with it I'm really good with
what I did well a lot of people are not
now I'm moved on to this one Pastor is
not he's very not happy about it really
did he did he cut the footage of it yes
oh so he paid for the society no he cut
to the trailer he showed the trailer
from the society okay at first I was
like hold on this this guy
posting exclusive Society content this
is what a lot of people do they don't
they read they get enough of it to say
that they just want to use it to make a
point but they don't want to sit there
and like actually watch the content
in its entirety and draw like an within
the a contextual situation draw a
complete conclusion
you know I've seen enough of this to now
instead of see all of it and yes it is
behind a paywall sorry
um preacher uh whoever you are
but like and I've seen enough of this to
now make perpetuate
just the conclusions that I'm coming to
that are like a little short
cited I mean if you haven't watched the
whole thing and yet you're going to take
it down it's like come on at least give
it just at least at least give me a
chance at least give Topo chica just so
you understand I don't think this pastor
watching the entire video is going to
change his mind I think it's only going
to make him more upset maybe he would
have I I would have liked for him to see
the conversation that I had I'm sure it
wouldn't matter okay
uh you know I'm sorry I'm just saying I
don't think his mind is open to that so
but this was two different ideas right
so um well yes I end up watching a lot
of this content and I'm just genuinely
fascinated by it and I'm not just not
just the stuff that's about us being
taken down but like I watch a lot of
like most of it is not about for us no
no just to be totally clear right uh I
watch a lot of ex-vangelical like
deconstruction stuff and and then like
um there's a couple of people
that are really good about sort of
breaking down certain things and one of
my favorite guys is uh I think his name
is Dan McClellan but he he's like a
Bible scholar and he'll like take
something that somebody says and then
kind of like give the
correct perspective on things but
occasionally this demon stuff will pop
up and the thing that was popping up
more often than
demon eraser was there's an exorcist uh
who's an older guy I think he's got a
church in Arizona Bob Larson and this
guy's been around for years and he's
older meaning in his 60s or yeah okay
and
he's like in a church context doing
these crazy exorcisms and his content is
just posting the exorcisms he's got like
a cross and he's like placing it on
people's heads and people are convulsing
and doing all this crazy stuff
and
you know
so it's like church footage
well
it's not Church footage it's not it's
he's filming it so that he will be able
to post these exorcisms okay it's like
it's all produced it's like this is what
he does and they and he's doing it in a
crowd he's doing it he's doing it like
some church in it or wherever he's at
and there's like people coming up and
there's like people holding these people
back and they're going crazy and and
he's eventually like casting them out
and then they're okay at the end you
know they all kind of go the same
so there was that guy and then I guess
demon eraser it's really the account is
demon erasers but I call Brian the demon
eraser Brian is sort of the face of
demon erasers he's the face of the
conglomerate as I call it
so I I was just fascinated because you
know when you got Bob Larson who's an
older guy who's been doing this thing
for a while but then you've got Brian
who's a younger guy whose main Outlet is
you know modern social media and Tick
Tock right and his account wasn't very
old it didn't have too many videos but
when so when we were in one of our
brainstorming meetings you showed demon
eraser to me well but before that we
were like oh we wanted to do the
Dungeons and Dragons thing everybody was
kind of into this idea we didn't and we
were like this is great because the
movie's coming out if we could get it to
come out around the time the movie's
coming out that's even better you know
tie in with that Zeitgeist thing
but we didn't really have an angle it
was like Rhett and Link play Dungeons
and Dragons and as we were getting into
these videos we wanted to have more
Sensational angles that are more fun to
watch right and then that was when we're
like What if we combine these two ideas
that was the Breakthrough when it was
like we can hire an exorcist he has a
damn form on his website
this is it and it was just and you know
like oh you're jumping ahead though
because he was he was an archetype yeah
we were like we're gonna get somebody
like and you can like we talked to the
rest of the team we're like you guys can
research and if there's somebody else to
be found like we can pick the right
person I've never had any idea that he
would be a you know willing to do it and
B just up the road in Bakersfield like
the fact that that worked out
so we felt like it was a huge
breakthrough it's like yes we
have cracked this video it's not just
it would be fun to document us learning
how to play and talking about our
upbringing but creating
an honest experiment
like I just started to get really
excited because I was like this sounds
hilarious
but
it also sounds kind of scary it sounds
risky on a number of levels there's a
lot of unknowns and so then it became
less about it being funny and more about
it tapping into
my curiosity
what will happen if we really do this in
an open-ended way like what's the story
going to be I definitely knew that we
did not want to make a prank video it
was that was very obvious to both of us
yeah from the very beginning but it was
also very obvious that this concept
could easily be a joke on any number of
people you know everybody involved or
just one per you know people who's in on
the joke
well and we're like Well everybody's in
on the joke because it's not a joke
and it's it is important to us but we
knew that it would be entertaining that
we're approaching it or we were hoping
as they like as an uh as an honest
experiment the yeah with such a great
hook
and
yeah I didn't want to manipulate it you
know it's like I'm very happy with where
the where we landed with this video
first of all it's 40 minutes
I'm like more than that I think over 40.
but it's like
yeah we're making we're making things
that I think require this amount of time
you know it feels less like something
you can just watch and blow over and
forget it ever happened you know it's a
piece that's the type of thing that I'm
excited about to do too and we're doing
what we did in the first video which is
we're talking about it before it gets
released right and so we don't know what
people are going to react so I'll make a
couple of predictions that may uh now
that the video is out when you're
watching this you can you can tell me if
I was right or wrong and then after that
can we just talk about
demons more yeah yeah okay good
um
I think because it
it will make people uncomfortable right
watching it's an uncomfortable situation
that's the thing that's exciting to us
about it you've got a guy who thinks
that what we're doing is a demonic
activity
and we're doing it right there in front
of him and we're literally turning to
him to consult with him and we've
invited three players a dungeon master
and two players who are established you
know you can watch their content online
uh it was I did not meet them until that
day we sat basically we sat down at the
table with them and introduced them to
Brian the demon eraser right so it's
like yeah it puts them in this I don't
know how they're gonna react well there
are they were they were prepped they
were they were it was explained what was
going to happen to them they weren't
blindsided by it but but also didn't
know what their posture was going to be
towards it but people there's a certain
percentage of the world and a certain
percentage of our audience that is not
comfortable
making people uncomfortable with
anything that is uncomfortable and so
and I listen I can't that that's your
prerogative uh we that's not where we're
at like we wouldn't do this if we if we
didn't like the idea of it right uh like
I showed the video to Shepard and he
just loved it you know and he's more
like me it's like the the um the
discomfort and the fact that this oh you
put you created this social situation
that was like what is going to happen
like that's the thing that gets us
excited yeah that's why we made all
those local commercials with people and
we made weird commercials with people
who've never been on camera before like
we love that stuff when you don't know
how it's going to be received
yet you know that it's going to be
talked about
is an exciting and it's an invigorating
place to be now
what's the other thing people are going
to give feedback on you got other
predictions I'm sure like some people
are they're going to be in the they have
us their beliefs in in to some degree
align with Brian the demon eraser
I don't even think it's necessarily
about what we'll talk about how you know
how our beliefs where they line up and
where they used to line up and whether
they did or not line up but that's a
part that's a group of people well
they're on some spectrum and then
there's like Avid DND Enthusiast players
who are like they're going to have their
own opinions and by the way some of them
might not have anything to do with the
exorcism to a demonologist part of it
all it might just be like
you didn't do us you didn't do Us
justice like I felt like I wanted
well there might be criticism to just
the just the D and D play of it all and
how we that was edited I don't know
um this one of the things I'm
anticipating
is
because I see it so often again I watch
takedowns and one of the things that I
consistently see is
when I feel like I'm actually being
really fair-handed when it comes to
talking about Christianity and I try to
I you know because I have so many people
in my life who are still Christians
still Evangelical still conservative
evangelicals yeah that you love and I
love them and we have meaningful
relationships and meaningful
conversation and I haven't like pushed
them out of my life and I was you know I
disagree but I respect where they're at
and realize that they come to their
conclusions through their own process
and I'm not I'm much less Evangelistic
than I ever was as a Christian but I
think there's something about
this is my theory at least I think
there's a lot of projection that happens
when certain Christians watch us talk
about these things because they assume
that our main goal and anytime we bring
out Christianity is to just tear it down
and pull people away right
and sure I am tempted at times uh when
we talk about these things to do that
but more often than not I'm just kind of
just presenting my perspective on
something and being like this I'm just
you know I'm I got a lot of outlets
where we just talk about things the goal
is not to change people's minds the goal
is to just share where we're coming from
but I think that what people are going
to think because they tend to be like oh
here's rep bashing Christianity again I
mean I'll I'll talk about my album or
I'll talk about new merch that I've got
and kind of explain the symbolism behind
it and then the some of the comments
will be oh you're bashing Christianity
again it's like what I I don't I didn't
I don't see where I did that so I think
because there's this projection of
thinking that if you're talking about
something you're you're trying to
persuade people you're tearing something
down people will assume oh link are now
officially beginning that their videos
where they tear Christianity down
directly and they did it with this DND
video and like that's not what we're
thinking at all we're like oh we want to
play Dungeons and Dragons because we
weren't ever ever able to do it there
are people who legitimately believe that
Dungeons and Dragons is a demonic thing
wouldn't it be cool to put all those
things together in the same room won't
that be fun interesting who knows what's
going to happen like that's our
motivation right but we didn't we never
sought to put Brian the demon eraser
Exorcist demonologist in the position of
representing all people of
Christian faith right uh and I don't
even think well we're not interested in
doing that and I don't think we did that
so
we're going to get into like how we like
how our beliefs interact with everything
that we were that was happening but I do
think there's one other group right
there's the group that's like you didn't
you were too sympathetic to this guy
exactly so it's like there's some people
who are like well you're using him as
like a straw man to take down
Christianity not the case and then
there's other people that's like you got
to you should have gone with the for the
jugular for this guy you should have
made him into a complete butt of the
joke
and
yeah you know we just wanted to present
him for who he is and every
a member of the audience is just coming
to their own conclusions this is not a
propaganda piece in any way but like
I think that's the other criticism oh
you should have taken him down hard or
there might be people who's like you
gave this guy a platform gave him a
platform now people know about his
account now people are going to go there
and and he's going to remove their
demons it's like
well that may happen I think that could
happen I think ultimately my answer to
all of that is that I know where our
hearts are at and I know what our
motivation for making the video is and
I'm very comfortable with that and if I
were to get into a place where I tried
to anticipate every segment of an
audience's uh
you know perspective and anticipate
their reaction and try to accommodate
their reaction in the content we would
never make any videos
especially not not this nature and this
is just exciting I mean and so we set
the ground the foundation the groundwork
with the team to help them understand
like the parameters of what we were
interested in and everything that we've
just talked about and so then we're kind
of we kind of entrust everyone to do
their part
so like just one example I mean you
could look at anything and see it's not
just everybody who touches the video and
who's worked on the team like has an
impact on every single moment of it
another part of the fun of it
but here's one example once it cuts to
the Montage of
the demon eraser at the beginning and
it's just his Tick Tock footage demons
go to church you'll notice that it's
just a montage of his footage it doesn't
I don't and this is the this is a bin
choice
say because he told me after the fact
like I did I saw the edit and I was like
this works but like what I didn't think
about was well you know what you could
have you could have kept cutting back to
us in this in like our office doing our
talking head thing and we could have
provided commentary on it or it could
have just cut back to us and we're
making a funny face and you could easily
get an additional
you could get a laugh out of our
reaction to it or you could get
information
maybe it's not just a laugh you could
get information
about what we thought about him
but what we wanted to do was just
present him
and it's a montage so we put I think
it's still in the cut there's a note at
the bottom something to the effect of
all of these clips are taken out of
context
and which do we really have to say that
for Montage but we did because it's like
hey this is what he puts out on the
internet and here's like an edited
version of it that's it's it's pruned
and primed for a reaction but we're not
going to spoon feed you a reaction that
you can just
uh emulate our reaction or disagree with
our reaction come to your own conclusion
yeah I think that was important um
I don't know why I said I think that was
important but link that was important
was that important yeah well so I do
think it was I I think it was important
to talk about all these things because
there's a lot of pitfalls is what I was
trying to go with it no no again who
knows who knows like you can never
answer us that's the weird thing about
making these videos is like what if it's
like so many people got mad about this
for this thing that we didn't anticipate
it's right I don't know that's part of
the excitement I'm having to embrace
that I because I have no other choice
but I'm not going to stop making stuff
we're not going to start throwing things
out there and seeing what happens but
like you said this was this isn't in New
Territory
ear biscus is brought to you by
betterhelp you like to getting to know
people what if yeah those people are
yourself oh that's interesting you know
because you can get to know yourself in
therapy it's a great way to say oh
that's
why I do that that's and of course I do
that on this podcast a lot I try to
learn more about myself by bouncing
myself off of you yeah just like
um I also do that a lot in therapy and
it's extremely helpful yes therapy is a
great way to help you get a deeper
understanding of yourself because you're
always changing and evolving good point
uh and we're big fans of therapy can we
make that even more clear I don't think
so and we want therapy to be accessible
to everyone and so does better help yeah
you know one of the things that therapy
has been so helpful uh with me is that
there are these different roles that you
play in your life right so I'm a friend
I'm a husband I'm a father I'm a
business owner and sometimes when I
start talking about those different
roles that I play I'll find oh there's a
lot of anxiety or difficulty frustration
in this one thing and if I hadn't gone
to therapy had my appointment with my
therapist and actually talk through this
uh it would have just sat under the
surface and maybe gone unresolved for
weeks and who knows it began affecting
me physically I mean that happens with
me sometimes when I don't deal with
something
um right that's one of the things and
one of the areas that therapy has been
so helpful for me in yeah so if you're
thinking about starting therapy give
better help a try it's entirely online
so you can have your sessions anywhere
you're comfortable and it's suited to
your schedule you just fill out a
questionnaire and they will match you to
a licensed therapist that meets your
specific needs and you can always switch
therapists at no extra cost so discover
your potential with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com ear today to get 10 off
your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash ear
all right so to kind of establish a
little bit about what you know how would
we have interacted with with Brian and
his beliefs
20 years ago let's go let's go back 20
let's go back 30 years ago yeah well we
already said we never played it
and the only reason wasn't for for
beliefs it was just like
our friends didn't play it really it
wasn't we didn't have a lot of
opportunities to play it wasn't like Hey
kid you want to play Dungeons and
Dragons and we were just like no
I
I don't want to crack I want to go
roller skating you know was it well
everything that we thought about it was
just based on a few things that had been
said to us right
very very prevalent within the
Evangelical community at the time was
that
you know this was on the level of heavy
metal music but worse right so these are
things that are from Satan they
celebrate satanic things and they invite
demonic forces into your life in general
was what we thought but
we grew up Baptists right
and then non-denominational basically
kind of Baptist but in that world that
we grew up in which is you know what you
would say is not a Pentecostal church
it's just just to illustrate the point
that Christianity is not monolithic
whatsoever
we believed theoretically in the
existence of demons but we would have
said that they were not very active at
least not in America like there was
there's always this uh there's this sort
of unspoken thing that like
the areas in the world where people are
kind of messing around with
um animistic you know religions and
Native religions and stuff like that
like oh over in Africa or in South
America like that's where the Demonic
activity is because their religions are
like really tied into it or whatever so
if you're a missionary and you go over
to those places you might see some
demonic activity but in our circles it
wasn't like oh somebody's sick that's a
demon somebody's got a mental illness no
no that's that's possession there were
Nev we never witnessed an exorcism our
preachers never did exorcisms When you
pray for somebody to get healed you
don't talk about demons you might talk
about like the activity of the devil and
what the devil is doing to scheme but we
always saw demons and the devil as a bit
more sophisticated it was like oh well
you know the greatest trick the devil
ever pulled is convincing the world that
he didn't exist that was the mindset
that we were in it was just like did you
just quote C.S Lewis because according
to the demon eraser he's demonic no I
quoted uh The Usual Suspects oh
[Laughter]
Spacey to be good to be exactly I think
I thought I thought you were Mere
Christianity well first of all maybe
that's that maybe C.S Lewis did talk
about that but so we would have said
that the that there was much more
demonic activity at say a liberal
University where they're teaching things
that undermine traditional ideas that's
where the that's the sophistication of
the devil is such that he's going to use
the intellectualism of mankind to
unravel The Godly ways of thinking that
was what we thought we weren't like but
not through this person's going to get
possessed and we're going to like throw
some holy water on him like no we we
thought that that was probably BS even
as Christians just letting you know we
never delved into this
demons are super active and they're on
people and they're in people no I didn't
know people
who thought that and and had experiences
that we can talk about oh let's talk
about that
but one more thing was that we missed
the Harry Potter
cavalcade when that first when the books
first started coming out it's like we're
already too old for that but
be in our church environment the younger
kids were discouraged
if not
told not to read those books because
they referenced things that were
of the devil witchcraft yeah it was like
Wizardry stay away don't become enamored
with that stuff don't become a neighbor
with it it opens a door to
you being open to more of Satan or his
demons influences so
and we did believe that
Satan or I guess his demons like we
never talk about demons we just talked
about Satan as if Satan was everywhere
all at once and he was
um or it was I don't know what the
pronoun I think he is I haven't asked
Satan it's pronouns Lucifer
Lucifer
um I'm just saying according to the
Bible they yeah okay they tempted you
I'm using they okay I like that
[Laughter]
[Music]
Satan would tempt me if I wanted to do
something that I shouldn't do I'd be
like
um stand behind me Satan yeah yeah we
but we didn't really give but I wasn't
scared of Satan because I didn't I just
felt like I was causing enough trouble
and I just felt like it was from myself
anyway
I just I didn't really fixate on the
Lucifer of it all you know
you know I knew I wasn't going to hell
because I I you know I'd accepted Jesus
we also thought that you couldn't be
possessed if you were a Christian
because the Holy Holy Spirit is inside
of you so that there was no place for
the demons to go because they get inside
there and they see God they can see
Jesus in your heart and they have to
leave
you know
no more room at the end yeah right Jesus
is taking up shop here he learned his
lesson you know Jesus he's gonna get in
early
I Ain't Gonna Keep sleeping on them
mangers A Manger is is what livestock
eat out of right
yeah we don't I mean yeah
this isn't a Christmas episode
here I'm just explaining my joke yeah
yeah
usually when you have to explain that
Jesus learned his lesson yeah I know it
was pretty good I didn't think you had
to explain it it was great it was great
to begin with but uh and I think Satan
did Satan approve of that joke I don't
know did he did he tempt me to am I an
agent of Satan in the fact that I made
that joke some people might believe I am
oh yeah a lot of people believe that we
are
but we did know people who
um
I knew well and I trusted and who I
believe are honest
Who had who had experiences with demons
uh and when they
you know
conveyed those experiences to me I'm
still convinced to this day
that whatever it is they experienced
at least as it manifested itself in
their minds
was real to them give me details
um
people who are missionaries okay who had
been to you know
other parts of the world which
interestingly let me I'll just let me a
little sidebar here
uh you know first of all I think that
Christian missions are based in white
white supremacy you know and it's pretty
clear that that's in the history of
Christian Mission is very much a white
supremacist thing
um where you bring your philosophy and
you come in with the understanding that
the brown people who you are visiting
and what they believe is inferior to
what you believe and also you
contextualize it within your own
tradition and say the things that they
worship are actually the bad parts of
your religion they're it's satanic you
know you contextualize it within your
framework and then you come in and you
adjust then you justify eradicating
their belief now up until very recently
you you also uh Justified eradicating
them as people you said they weren't
even people and you eradicated them and
you establish you know look at what
Spain and or the Spanish and the the
British did
in the Americas yeah and if you if
you're watching the the series 1923
which I don't watch Yellowstone I've
never gotten into it but I'm into the
prequels
1923 God I mean has a heartbreaking
visceral
storyline uh that explores this and I
yeah okay so I watched the first two
episodes I think so I haven't done the
slow down so the so interestingly
there's so much of this thought and this
underlying Foundation that still is very
active within the church and this is
stuff that was I had no idea about when
I was a part of it
but hold on you were telling me about
the demons your missionary friends who
saw demons that's what I'm getting back
to we'll get back to that I'm setting
the stage for it good because
I find it
interesting that uh that you go into
these situations where you're
interacting with brown and black people
and their religions and yours you're
assuming that what they're all involved
in is witchcraft
and so I'm saying that that is
very racist it's just very very racist
let's just be honest about it now you
may say well my Bible says that you know
it's either either if you're not for God
you're against him so it's it's all
within the Christian context and I
understand that your world view
because I had the same world view in the
past it was all it was all Christians so
it was like everything that wasn't of
God was of Satan
but I just I think it's important to
just tease that a little bit and
question that and challenge that a
little bit because the fact is that when
you come into a place and the assumption
is that what these people are doing in
all their rituals and all their
background and their culture which is
who they are it defines who they are is
based in evil
that is a there's so many racists over
undertones to that
a note okay
but
because because it's interesting that
that's when you're when you're in a
little bit more of a uh you know
Pentecostals or whatever like demons are
everywhere if you talk to Brian like I
don't know what his background is but
demons are everywhere they're not just
in those places like he's got demons
everywhere
but from the from where we were coming
from it's like well you might encounter
some of these more uh more obvious
manifestations of demonic activity if
you go into these places I'm just making
the point that that's coming from a
racist place
but the people that I knew had those
experiences
um
so I'll just kind of go through a couple
of the stories there was one story in
which
someone was grabbed very like forcefully
on the shoulder while they were sleeping
right when they were in the in the in
like the middle of sub-Saharan Africa
right just the bit of demonic activity
but this is one of your friends who's
describing being grabbed themselves uh
yes uh there was someone
um who jumped
like up onto something that they
shouldn't have been able to jump up onto
okay and were they being was the demon
inside of them being uh confronted in
this moment I don't
know okay
there was another
person turned
to
my friend
they open their mouths and things grew
fangs fangs grew
so those are those are a couple of
examples now do I believe
that this person and these people it's
just multiple people uh had experiences
where they believed these things happen
yes do I believe
that Supernatural things actually
happened and there were fangs that were
grown and there were Supernatural
Heights that were achieved
almost certainly not
because it's so much more likely that
based on the world view and the
perspective that they were bringing with
themselves and the way that they saw the
environment that they were in the mind
is incredibly powerful you can
rationalize so many things you can
convince yourself of so many things that
it's just so much because it's been
demonstrated and you don't have to be
like clinically
insane to to see these things or to
experience of these things right I I
think that it's just my perspective is
most likely there's no there there
the other option is that maybe there is
some there there and there is some
Supernatural thing that people tap into
and experience but the conclusion that
because those things happen and can be
experienced by certain people then it is
necessarily true that this one
particular perspective on those events
the Christian perspective is the right
one like that's an unnecessary leap
right why can't it just be ghosts why
can't it be a ghost that grabbed you
or
I mean the fangs thing that's that's a
little different I guess what I'm saying
I wasn't there and and I'm not saying I
may I may and I'm still open to being
able to experience something that is a
clear you know we've talked about this
in my deconstruction update that I'm
open to experiencing quote unquote
Supernatural things or things that are
beyond our understanding and things that
Define defy the laws of physics as we
currently understand them and I think
the world would be a cooler more
interesting place if that is the case
but I can't prove it and I definitely
can't experience it that experience it
and then base in my beliefs
or endorse a belief system based on my
experience because my experience is too
unreliable
and so because my experience is too
unreliable I don't think that someone
else's experience is going to be more
reliable than mine
you know I'm not going to be like okay
you experienced that that's all I needed
to hear
it's funny it's so interesting that like
we believed in Satan we believed in
demons we believed in angels because
there's references in the Bible
you know
apparently there's a lot of other extra
Bible books that go into a lot more
detail that give you a lot more fodder
if you want to be a a demon eraser
you know different books but I just kind
of wrote it off you know and there were
other churches where it's like they're
doing lots of things that are just
dictated by belief okay if you believe
that you can speak in tongues well you
need to go to another type of church
where that will be welcomed and then it
it happens a lot over there but it never
once happens here you know if you if you
feel like that your sickness is a result
of demonic activity well you better go
over there and I'm talking about like a
maybe sometimes a few blocks away from a
church that will believe something
totally different than the ones than
what we believed right so it's just like
you get in the right group of people it
seems like you can start to explain that
like if it you know they work themselves
up into we all we all get into groups
and we work ourselves up into what we
can agree on
and what we can say yes and or no don't
and find another place for that and so
then people start to group up and is it
that the demons are grouping up with
these people over here and then
everybody over here so when you get sick
and you're you're in this group it's
because demons are getting you sick but
when you get sick over here it's because
well you're sick and you just need to go
to like you need to seek medical
attention
well I think from and it didn't but but
it was weird that we were in this
strange place where it's like I believed
in Satan I believed in demons I believed
in angels but I I just we had a specific
beliefs about it that wrote it off
whereas other people played it up well
we definitely didn't think that anybody
who was getting sick in any place was a
result of demonic activity
but we right we had a lot of criticisms
of
Pentecostal you know Pentecostal church
and like charismatic thinking like we
thought that
the whole speaking in tongues thing was
just an emotional thing you know again
it was just your mind playing tricks on
you and like people can just work
themselves up and like are they really
speaking in like the tongues of Angels
or whatever or other languages and that
kind of thing
we didn't really believe that that was
we were and we also believed
I guess we were dispensationalists
and that we believed that those there
was a time and a place there was a time
for that and it's passed and it was
basically Miracles it was basically the
book of Acts you know
[Music]
um
it was that initial okay the initial
establishing of the church God would use
the it's just so signs and wonders it's
so amazing again it's just an example of
how you can rationalize anything so as a
Christian who was looking around and
seeing a world that seemed natural that
did not seem Supernatural I didn't see
evidence of demons I didn't see evidence
of Satan's activity at least not in
those really like fangs type of way you
know yeah this physical manifestation
again it was these things happening at a
higher level
but because the Bible clearly describes
demon possession and demons making
people sick and demons being cast out of
people and put into pigs that didn't go
off cliffs Jesus did that and then
there's these things that happen in the
book of Acts because those things happen
and we believe that those are true
historical accounts we had to reconcile
those things and so the way we
reconciled them of course we didn't
reconcile them somebody some other
apologist some Bible person did it for
us
they developed this idea that there's a
dispensation there's a time in which
these things happen and then it's over
and the reason we don't experience it is
because God has changed the way that he
works in the world it's like come on
guys get isn't it so clear that you're
just making it up as you go along I mean
I'm sorry I didn't want to make it about
this but like it's I'm just saying it
makes you feel that way it's when I look
back on it I'm like oh like I mean come
on
or the yeah and it's if you go to a
Pentecostal church and you're like you
said I'm I'm I'm really feeling this I'm
going to open my mouth and I'm gonna
spray in tongues I'm gonna do it and
then you go for it and it works well
you're in yeah you know you're in more
and if you go for it and it doesn't work
and it's like you start to think maybe I
need to go somewhere else and then where
I can
I can surround my thinking with a belief
structure that makes me feel okay with
what I'm not doing
I don't know it just seems it's I don't
know I always tend to go back to this we
all believe we want to believe I know I
believe what I want to believe I know
that about me I just know that's a big
party human nature it's just an impulse
and it's just like you can you can work
some acrobatics
but yeah so the dispensation of it all
that is the answer for us that like I
didn't worry about demons I did I pre
practically didn't believe in deemed
demonic activity
in in my life or in my presence yeah
yeah or in my world view when we prayed
we prayed
according to God's will we talk to God
and of course we would say you know if
it's your will Lord this thing be done
which is a whole different conversation
but we would pray and just ask God to do
things
heal this person
if they got healed praise God if they
didn't get healed God thank you for this
experience you know you know what's best
or whatever but there was never
if there's a demon here if there's a
cancer demon
can we cast out the cancer demon
which is again what Brian what Brian
believes you know one of the things and
you obviously it's very very
clear in the video but we talked to
Brian for a really long time
and basically
I don't even know if this is still in
there the nuts
demon well I know that the peanuts joke
it was just an observation uh is still
in there but you said it kind of feels
like there's demons everywhere yeah and
it almost got to this place where it was
like
the world feels a little bit
meaningless like is it true
from that if your perspective is that
demons are in everything and there's so
many places like demons might be in this
computer or if if somebody's looked at
porn on my computer boy it wasn't me
but if somebody's looked at porn on my
computer then there's like a porno
pornaya demon on this computer right or
my phone my phone's never my phone's
never seen porn
what do you mean so play being so weird
so there's demons on this phone there's
demons in books there's demons and rocks
if there's demons everywhere
then God created a world in which the
thing that's more real than the senses
that he gave you to experience the world
is something that's below the surface
I don't know man it's and the thing that
you talked about was or or we I think we
did keep this in the video where it was
like is it that like if I were to talk
about the spells that I was casting and
I'm talking about them in a profession
to make to the group okay as if it's a
chemical reaction yeah um I Can Do Magic
but it's not technically magic it's
technically chemistry you know what I'm
saying does that mean the demons are
like you were talking about yeah does
that fool the demons and I was doing
that because this is what Brian was I
again I think it's important to talk
about like what are our position was as
we entered the video and mine was very
much like
Clean Slate like I'm going into it in
this place where I can make myself
really open to stuff I I'm I'm like if
I'm going to hang out if I'm going ghost
hunting with a ghost hunter I'm not
going in there like some skeptic I'm
going in thinking go surreal I'm gonna
see one I spend the night at a haunted
hotel and I was I was trying to make
stuff happen like I was like I'm open to
it ghost if you're here show yourself to
me like
and I'm open to it man like I want to
see it
it's just more fun to live that way for
me right so I was able to I don't know
where you were at but I was able to put
myself in a position where it was like
all right I'm going into the situation
thinking that anything that I have
thought about this previously is I'm
throwing it out the window and like this
guy has this very specific perspective
we're bringing him in we're saying that
he's going to kind of advise us and
these people are doing this thing
they're going to be a little bit
uncomfortable with this guy talking
about demon stuff but we're going for it
um but it's just really early in the
process it became very evident to me
that we were just playing a game
right
I thought
I just didn't I did I never thought that
demons might show up
I didn't think that he was going to say
don't do that there's a I thought he
might say
that I sense there's a demon here you
know more of like a like what a psychic
who was channeling somebody
like
someone with the S name is trying to
get through to someone about a pendant
does anyone here have a relative with an
asset you know a medium medium medium so
he don't he doesn't do that but he
didn't eat it but he would he would
directly condemn that as a matter of
fact yes he would he would I thought he
would say up there's a demon here the
shit's hitting the fan I gotta I gotta I
gotta start using my blow torture so I
didn't know but yeah and then I was like
okay this is just the only mess that
we're gonna have to clean up is any
relational mess here and I'm here for
that
you know I didn't want to create it but
I wanted to
create a space for it
you know so that's what I was interested
in was
what can happen what's the interplay
between these these people and
I was happy with where it landed because
I felt like the approach was honest
and the results were pretty honest the
fact that like
we played the game
it what nothing nobody was Ultra
offended on either side of it and I
don't know how many sides there actually
were maybe at least three but
um I don't know somehow
everybody was kind of brought a little
bit closer together you know you
tolerated your differences and when they
were pretty prickly and you might feel
like you were getting that was directed
at me type of thing one way or another I
feel like everybody just put their best
foot forward and we had a fun evening
best credit Brian
um here's the thing about Brian
is that yes he believes
very very honestly and sincerely
that demons are very active and that
Dungeons and Dragons should not is not a
good thing to play right and but even
though he believes that
and he will tell you this is what he's
basing that on and
um he's not a jerk about it he's not a
jerk about it you know and he's not uh
he he was not
judge I mean here's okay judgmental in
the sense that he's judging the things
that are happening and saying well
that's a demon or that's not a demon but
at no point
dude I feel and I appreciate this about
him
personally judged and I don't think that
uh he said anything neces I mean
obviously just the fact that he believes
these things there's inherent judgment
in that if you're somebody who's like
based your like professional career on
DND like the people that we had there
so is there some implied judgment but I
think that he was very gracious towards
uh the individuals who were there and
was you know and by the end of it he's
like making noises and trying to you
know be a part of things and uh so I
probably still remaining true to his
beliefs I appreciate that about him I
disagree with his his world view and I
and I don't think that there's you know
I don't believe in it I don't think that
there's adequate evidence for it
um and I'm sure that we would disagree
about many many things
um but in terms of the way that he
interacted with us on a personal level
it was you know
a lot of people who have done takedowns
of me and you on the internet could
learn a thing or two just about how uh
you know friendly he is yeah you know I
don't know what he actually believed
about me or you you know the fact that
like yes my tattoo have getting a tattoo
is problematic
you know
in his opinion getting a tattoo of
Elvish which is demonic writing his
opinion is problematic it opens you up
and it makes you friendly with the the
Demonic world
what do you think about the people who
are going to say well even if I don't
believe everything that Brian believes I
do believe in a spiritual realm I do
believe in demons more than you guys
ever did and that they do have some sort
of sway over people on some level maybe
it's not as ubiquitous as Brian believes
it may you know maybe you fall in a
slightly different place but what about
the kids it's like you're basically
making the light of the kids huh what
about the kids what about the children
of the world that are watching our video
that's what is it did I answer your
question yeah did you have a question I
just said what about the kids what about
the kids who are watching our video
and
obviously Rhett and Link are not scared
and they're making light of the fact
that there is a there's a spiritual
realm and some bad can go down
there and you're just you're you're and
anesthetizing them to it Anastasia
whatever the word is you're making them
numb to it you're making them open to it
that was really the Practical Crux of
where Brian was coming from it's like
yeah even if there's not a demon here
right now
we're kind of saying Bring It On
so I mean that question has been asked
not just about this video but about us
deciding to talk about these things in
general right right
and that question for me only makes
sense
it is only a legitimate question if your
starting point is that Christianity is
true the Bible is true and so anything
that potentially undermines it is going
to be
bad for the kids
and I'm asking the question I'm not
saying this but how come it isn't the
case that Christianity is bad for the
kids you know what I'm saying I'm not
saying it is what I'm saying is you have
to send you have to Center that question
from from the framework from from a from
a POV and
what about the kids well what about the
kids
do you like is it better for the kids to
grow up thinking that Dungeons and
Dragons is a fun game
powered by human imagination and
cooperation
or is it better for them to think that
it's crawling with demons or even might
be crawling with demons and therefore
they should stay away from that and
while they're at it they should stay
away from anything that any sort of talk
of witchcraft
why
I mean if I had to if I had to put my
foot down on one side of that issue
right now I would say I think it's much
better for the kids
to
see Dungeons and Dragons as a fun game
of about imagination and cooperation and
I do think we did that I mean in making
the video we pretty much did that
because
we played it and we had a good time and
we presented it in a fun light
yeah yeah
because I mean and to answer that
question like on a holistic level like
if I didn't think that us talking about
these things
was
more
Illuminating than it was debilitating
we wouldn't do it like if I thought that
us talking about these things these
spiritual things and giving our
perspective was a net negative for the
people listening and I wouldn't talk
about it right
you know I'm not we don't talk about
these things
despite the number of people who've said
this because there's more money and and
and and being on talking about these
things and being we're interested in it
you know in the story end of story you
know we probably we would probably if it
turns out that I you know we lose a lot
of followers every time we talk about
this stuff it's like there's not there's
not great money and criticizing
um and talking sort of critically about
the most popular religion in the world
and overwhelmingly the most popular
religion in your own country which is
where our audience is mostly like
there's not great money in that FYI
um so yeah but we're not that we're just
we're just talking from our
you know we're just being honest about
things
um we're talking from our mouths and
from our asses sometimes yeah most of
the time for myself let's be real so I
don't believe in demons
but I'd like to be open to believing in
ghosts
but I'm not really I don't really
believe that either
but I know there's a lot of people who
do and there's they're just like are
they are there other Realms are there
other levels of that we're just like we
just have a little hints of their of the
existence of
other
planes of existence
spiritual or otherwise well if there is
some if there are other planes of
existence that through some sense that
we don't yet quite understand we have
the ability to tap into and some people
have the ability to tap into it more
readily than others
then if that's true which I'm very open
to that being a possibility when we talk
about creativity we're talking about
receiving
creative ideas from some external Source
I mean we use the term spiritual or
Supernatural because it's beyond just
the physical you know a materialistic
understanding of the world
I'm very open to that
but what's more likely is it more likely
that if there is some sort of thing that
can be tapped into that it's really hard
to understand what that is and people
experience it and then people try to
Define it and put it in a box and that's
where religion comes from
and that's why if you go all around the
world just within we just demonstrated
the how
and not monolithic Christianity is
there's so many different perspectives
just within this one faith and then once
you move beyond that into these other
Fates and they have people are
experiencing weird and people are
trying to explain it trying to reconcile
it trying to systematize it so that they
can relay it and talk about it and write
it down in a book somewhere
but I'm just saying that probably you
know from a probabilistic standpoint
if that stuff happens
your individual perspectives are
probably just wrong probably mistaken
and so that's why I'm not coming to any
hard conclusions about it
I don't think playing Dungeons and
Dragons makes you demonic I think it I
think it does make you a little open to
those Concepts and then if you start
getting into that part of it like oh I'm
gonna start reading about demons and
stuff you might start believing I don't
know what it could you know anything
could lead to something for somebody
depending on you know it's just like oh
don't don't even think about that
because who knows what it could lead to
it's like well but I don't think I don't
think there's
I think a much better argument could be
made about like
certain types of music with certain
subject matter right
so if there's like okay you're listening
to music right that is celebrating
murder murder
torture yeah right okay if you're if
you're like
this about torturing somebody
unfortunately you could be singing real
pretty about it no but I'm just saying
let's just say got in the torch into no
they're saying you're getting really
worked up yeah and you're like appealing
to the lowest common denominator now one
theory is that by getting that out
through music you're less likely to do
it in the real world I don't know or
maybe you're like you know you're
leaning into that and then yes that
could somehow like influence your
behavior I I could see how the case
could be made for that but
Dungeons and Dragons isn't doing any of
that it's completely based in this idea
that because there's warlocks and
witches and Magic
and those things are
and labeled in the Bible as evil and of
the devil it's just because those things
were part of the game
yeah the game just was like oh it's all
bad it's opening yourself up to these
but like
no you're just it's an imaginary world
it's like playing Zelda and which I
guess again is still a bad thing
if you follow that logic all the way
yeah I mean well yeah there's so many
games now for so many different reasons
that like you could again it's like
it was Dungeons and Dragons then it was
Harry Potter and now it's like
everything you shake a stick at is
probably something that's I mean yeah
definitely for Brian is gonna be demonic
you got to stay away from it that's why
I ended up asking him and it's not in
the edit it was like
in in a world where you're encountering
demonic activity at every turn every
turn
it's like what is that what kind of life
is that like I would be a wreck you know
yeah where where where's the fun and he
was like well I I have I have fun in in
having power over them
maybe there's an answer in that it's
like you know it's it's he has you know
he was so cool common collected he
wasn't afraid
you know so it's nice to believe all
these things when then you can believe
oh but I've you know I have power over
this through Jesus Jesus has power over
this and has given me access to it
however you want to say it
um maybe that is a really good feeling
for some people I mean I I don't
our video and now at this point I don't
want to either like start to
psychoanalyze
any more of like what draws people to
certain beliefs whether it's
like Brian's belief system or people who
play Dungeons and Dragons well but it's
I mean first of all
uh humans
it is has been reinforced through many
many generations that it's beneficial to
attach some sort of agency or some sort
of reason to things that you don't
understand like to Define things right
like there's a survival
advantage to believing that there's a
lion in the bushes when you hear
something move right like that you you
actually gain a survival advantage
foreign
by extrapolating and defining and most
people and we're we're two of them by
the way because we're people I'd say all
people have a tendency to want to just
you know like not just rest in this
uncertainty like it's
I don't know what Brian's day-to-day is
but like he wakes up and goes throughout
his day and there's no uncertainty for
him at least as as he communicates or on
the surface
of like the things that he experienced
it's just like that's a demon this is a
demon that's a demon and I'm kind of
living in a place where it's like well
some you know I woke up from a nap and
had an idea and then somebody in the
Next Room had the same idea what is
there something going on there I don't
know I'll lean into that a little bit
like some people are just not
comfortable with
kind of living in that Lev that level of
uncertainty where you want to Define it
you want to pin it down because it's
just easier to go on with your life if
you can just be like okay well I'm gonna
I'm gonna establish this you know there
is a God and
um you know this religion that I'm a
part of is true and it's like I I'm
gonna let me get these things in place
so I can just go on and live my life
and I just think there's a Temptation
for everybody to sort of come to a
conclusion like there's a Temptation for
us I think and I can hear it in you in
the way that you talk about these things
to just be like it's all fake you know
what I'm saying it's just not none of
this stuff's real this is all just
people's minds Playing Tricks on them
and it's it'd be easier to just be like
that's right it's all people's minds
Playing Tricks on them the human mind
has an incredible capacity I'm just for
imagination and everything can be
explained through just the power of
people's imagination and their their
ability to
you know rationalize manipulate their
own thoughts
and I'm gonna just be an atheist and
just move on with my life and I'm
tempted to do that at times oh yeah it's
easy and I'm like that's my that's my
that's where I
unless I make active decisions to be
open that's just where I fall back
I fall back into that and I would say
that that version of certainty but I
would say that like from a practical
standpoint
the only thing that I'll ever like stake
my claim on or like really try to defend
our our things that
I I can prove I'm like I will try to
convince you like I'm not gonna do it on
a regular basis and I don't do it on the
internet really but like if somebody
asked me in my personal life what I
think about
Evolution for instance because I think
there's so much great evidence for it
and I think it's an important thing to
understand and believe I'll I'll talk to
them about that because I think that
that that's not a real questionable area
that's like a pretty obvious thing
but like then there's stuff like this
like oh what's happening when
two people have you know two twins have
some crazy experience across the globe
right and there's all these evidence all
this evidence of it it's like uh well
I'm not gonna say that's their mind
playing tricks on them because it you
know who are you yeah it seems like it
happens
yeah and there must be something else
going on or maybe there is I'm open to
that
I'm not gonna try to convince you of it
though
I can't wait to see what the comments on
the video and also on this one you know
um anything else that we experience in
general pipe in here because you were
there all along the way too like
anything else that we experienced from
just a
people might be interested to know
inquiring minds want to know uh
in terms of the the process
uh no no one was harmed with the
lighting of the flamethrower
no property either everyone was totally
fine yeah it's that the flamethrower was
originally designed to be done outside
but it was raining yes
and so we were like let's do it in the
fireplace and when it happened
it was very intense but watching it back
you see just how high the Flames leap
out of the fireplace up onto like the
speaker underneath the TV and again it's
just a flash of fire it's not gonna do
anything and he seemed to have a lot of
control over it but there was a certain
level of trust he seemed to wanted to
keep doing it I love the fact they did
it twice
and then we found that footage uh that
we use at the beginning which
it's like a Canadian those television
show again I think this is where I think
some people would be like oh Rhett and
Link are trying to tear down the
Christians you know because like we show
this ridiculous video from the 80s and
the way that the guy like talks
I think we were talking about
his bottom lip uh
being very wet most of the time that he
was he was speaking nothing against the
guy I'm just saying that like uh it was
hard not to notice that and you know
well then put a he did like a side
camera effect that then goes around
maybe it de-emphasized the flip you know
you got these guys who even when we were
very very strong professional Christians
even missionaries
we would have been like these guys are
we would have we would have thought they
were hilarious we would have thought
those guys in that opening video were
hilarious you know yeah we probably kind
of agree with them on some level but
like I mean they're ridiculous
characters God for dispensationalism uh
but they mentioned in that opening video
about the
demons escaping the objects and
screaming yeah you know I was like oh
man we got to put a scream in in the
dice and the die the burning dice at the
end it was just a great bookend it's
beautiful man
and we haven't talked to Brian since
then we don't have an active
relationship with Brian
you know
we knew him in the moment well you know
I think we've made some memories and
that was it I think we utilized the
services yep uh we did and
um like like you said I think he spoke
for himself he he and I don't know what
he thinks of the video because he said
what he said yep did what he did uh he
was very consistent with his
um
perspective
and I'm sure that there are people who
are you know feel as if they are in need
of some sort of
help in fighting the demons are you
about to recommend Brian nope I'm just
saying if you're a wreck I'm just saying
that it's it's kind of an inevitable
consequence of
hey we use an exorcist and people know
where to find him so we okay so we got
you're going to recommend him and you're
going to recommend you're going to have
equal recommendations I'm not
recommending him and then you're going
to recommend he was saying that it was
sort of implied uh you can go see where
he's at what's your wreck then my wreck
is that you play Dungeons and Dragons
okay really I mean uh it was fun yeah I
uh and it was you know it was a little
bit of an interesting introduction to
the game typically an exorcist will not
be present when you're playing I would
think it's up to you though
um
and the main thing holding me back from
it of course is that you know we know
people who play on a regular basis and
it is a time commitment
and that is something that we do not
have in our lives at this point yeah but
maybe at some point we will uh
I could see how once she really
understood
the ins and outs of the game and uh
being with a you know Lamar was a great
dungeon master to see that on display
you know you know science Mike our
friend is a great dungeon master we've
never seen him in action but I can kind
of imagine how good he would be as well
yeah
um
but I think that I I highly recommend it
so find your local
DND group however however that's done
oh a demon just left you
[Music]
another demon just left you oh no
oh no he was only half out is he out the
person he's yeah took two sneezes
get them all the way out his hoofs were
caught he's gonna come back in no one
said bless you bless you bless you Brian
did say that
when you sneeze when you're on Burp when
you burp these are these are these could
be demons coming out of you and with
that let us know what you think
#your biscuits wherever hashtags are
used and call in and let us know how
your how you how the video struck you
and this conversation 1-88
earpod one
can we end this with a flamethrower
hey Rhett and Link this is Reese Knutson
Colin from Salt Lake City Utah
I was listening to the podcast and I
jumped in and left a voicemail earlier
because I was super excited about
Rhett's the certification but I should
have listened to the whole thing through
because Link's story
was so funny and so unfortunate but I
called my wife who works at Park City
and she was confirming that they do
incentivize
matching of people who are using someone
else's past so that is just it's all it
is is just a way for the resort to make
more money
really when it comes down to it even
though it's like yeah link paid for it
and he was just sort of it was all the
passes were paid for by him he was just
taking the day that's one of their ways
to make extra money so we empathize with
you link
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
foreign
[Music]